[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment hey
guys Danny will burn down King's Landing
and John will help to kill her that's
the tier we're going to talk about in
this video
Game of Thrones fans were stunned to see
Danny Targaryen was all over supporters
in recent episodes but it seems there's
more horde to come for a character says
one of the show's directors the mother
of Jagan discovered pretty much everyone
is team Jon Snow and without her most
loyal advisors and friend Jorah Mormont
around to protect her it seems the born
leader is in trouble
additionally very sincerely insert
threatening to put their support
somewhere else it seems there's a huge
disaster on the horizon according to one
on Game of Thrones directors then is
going to be terrifying in the final two
episodes speaking to the new york times
David Nutter who directed episode 4 has
suggested they need met Queen fate could
capture he said there's really a sense
that her character is getting a sense of
isolation realizing that Jorah Mormont
is no longer there David teased the
director continued that moment of
overhearing torment talking about how
jon is a king because he jumped on a
dragon and forth with a dragon when she
has done that multiple times and she is
not being recognized for it I think
that's an interesting reference point
for a character to deal with David went
on to discuss how she'll feel by episode
5 and although angry has an eerie calm
cool and collected nature here there's
an anger that comes out Emilia out of
Danny's character at the end of this
episode that I've never seen that of
Dany before I'm actually quite scared
about what she's going to do next but
what will they need next they're strong
hints suggesting that she'll be about to
fulfil the math Queen prophecy her
father was nicknamed the Mad King for
his incredibly threatening behavior
while ruling over restaurants he
eventually tried to burn King's Landing
when he was losing control but was slain
by Jaime Lannister
it appears then is heading the same way
as her dad and she was just cryptically
told to burn everything by me saying day
before her death does this mean Danny
will be slain before she can kill any
innocent people Game of Thrones favorite
Dany Targaryen is heading for a huge
fold
realizing she's not the rightful heir of
the armed man she's slowly slipping into
paranoia after she discovered just now
is Hef Targaryen and have Stark and
therefore being a male is next in line
additionally Danny's losing grip on her
own team after the last of the Starks so
very sentient lannister having a frank
and honest discussion about whether they
truly believe in her then he will be
forced to kill at least varus fulfilling
yet another prophecy from Melisandre in
season 7 very similar Sanjaya chat in
Dragonstone about the upcoming war and
better they should return to the
mainland
the former tells the red woman I don't
think you should return to Westeros I'm
not sure you'd be safe there Melisandre
cryptically replies I will return dear
spider
one last time I have to die in this
strange country just like you as when
snow melts Angie died in season 8
episode 3 man she sacrificed herself
following the victory in the long night
sorry that prophecy being true attention
has turned to wearisome matter he will
buy the dust in season 8 episode 4 danny
plans your line of attack on Cersei
Lannister in King's Landing however not
everyone is a fan of our plan which has
the potential to wipe out thousands of
innocent people very stelzer he is
concerned about the impact of her
strategy and promises he's being honest
but annie has been very of Varys
previously telling him and they first
met promise me Lord Varys if you ever
think I am failing the people you will
not conspire behind my back he promises
he will come to her but she still uses a
warning to him threatening and I swear
this if you ever betray me I'll burn you
alive Varys is no doubt about to launch
a dangerous plot against Danny as he
hinted to Tyrion he told the young
lannister you know where my loyalty
stands you know I will never betray the
realm
Tyrion responded what is the realm best
continent home to millions of people
most of whom don't care who sits on the
Iron Throne
Very's continued millions of people many
of them arrived the wrong person sits on
the throne we don't know their names but
they're just as real as you and I they
deserve to live they deserve food for
their children I will act in their
interest no matter the personal cost
betrayers prepared to sacrifice his life
for the good many will it be down to
Dana 2 : well it seems like tearing is
reconsidering his beliefs various has
already betrayed Danny and sided with
Jon Snow and then he will likely execute
him for that in Episode five then he did
warn him that if he ever sees another
person is more fatal than she is to tell
her that in her face and not to plot or
throw her behind her back
rather eyes should burn him alive and
what it varies do
they're hearing john is a Targaryen he
immediately started plotting behind her
back then he will then burn Mary slime I
believe here Danny commands great worm
to find him ringer very stoic seal him
for treason and this is shot of Tyrion
concerned and worried as a show marches
towards its end game Cersei Lannister is
planned to protect the civilians of
King's Landing by securing them in the
red keep to prevent any Targaryen from
attacking her is a brilliant move it
ensures that Dany cannot win the aren't
men without mass casualties and in turn
brings to mind and his father there is
the second Targaryen and his legacy of
madness and death it's a legacy that's
haunted Danian Targaryen sent one she
has been actively trying to avoid
falling victim to well Danny has been
trying to avoid following her father's
footsteps
she has been reminded in a few occasions
that she's displaying similar behavior
and the last of the Starks placed a lot
of emphasis on the possibility of Danny
descending into madness though your
mileage may vary on how effective
graceful or believable it was with the
scenes like Danny firming her brow and
glaring at the man celebrating chance
now or speaking extra abrasively during
the wartime discussions her behavior was
even shown to worry her advisors with
various asking Tyrion in private about
her mental state tyrion defuse the
situation as best as he could saying
that worrying about the Monarchs mental
state is part of their jobs as advisors
but that has not stopped fans from
speculating that Game of Thrones is
headed for an ending in which Danny
ghost may just like her father before
her and uses her last remaining dragon
innate magic for joke artists to burn
anything and anyone that would hinder
her from taking the aren't bound then
his father was known as the Mad King a
legacy she wants the void to understand
in Targaryen you have to understand her
family Game of Thrones has not actually
introduced many of Dana's relatives but
it's referenced them frequently over the
years her father errors the second was
known as the Mad King because he
eventually grew to be a spiteful
murderers usually by burning people in
deranged ruler his insanity was
ultimately attributed to the umbra ding
in the Targaryen family
one of the most nefarious things there
is the second is known for today is
hiding wildfire all over the King's
Landing to be able to torch any
perceived enemies set a moment's notice
if you remember Jaime previously
explained as much to Brienne in season 3
he burned anyone who was against him
said Jaime
before long half the country was against
them Aerys saw traitors everywhere so he
had his Pyromancer place caches of
wildfire all over the city
we saw some of Eris's stores in action
in season six and Cersei used wildfire
to burn down the Sept of Baelor with all
her adversaries inside Jaime was
actually part of his Kingsguard before
actually killing him and earning the
nickname King's lair went on to explain
how this plot was the reason he had
turned on Eris and why people believe
the Targaryen were so dangerous that
they should never rule again many
believe that any Targaryen no matter how
good or sane it might seem will
inevitably succumb their true nature
which share is displayed Eris was once
regarded as a warm and generous King
before his descent into madness which
was marked among other things by his
growing jealousy or the power of his
closest advisors similar as to Danny be
jealous or John and his claim and
popularity Eris is like a sea of are
obsessed madness is why Danny is so bent
on making sure that she wins the faith
over people and why she's so determined
to rule in a different way than those
who came before her remember how often
we've heard her say she wants to break
the wheel it's also why Tyrion Lannister
with versed wise ahem is constantly
urging Dany not to use blunt force to
take the city's specifically in season
six Tyrion told they needed to using her
dragons would make her no better than
her father the Mad King was killed after
attempting to burn down King's Landing
me saying this last world was jokers
suggesting she was calling on Danny to
do the same then his jealousy of Jon's
popularity is obviously growing as his
courage about Cersei's position in the
armed man now she knows that jack has a
better claim to the UH throne than she
does as much as skins is that he serves
her her advisors tyranny berries have
also expressed concern about her sanity
Cersei is aware of Dana's history as
well
which explains why Cersei has lain in
the depicting Daniel's amid Queen with
an army of savages searched SEC has
offensively called Danny the German
queen and uses phrase like foreign scum
to describe loot rocky it's also a
search that has made it so that Danny
will have to kill innocent people to get
to her to ensure that Dany appears to be
no better than her father but she lost
her trust over army and her closest
advisors and now that means saying they
made her last verge Icarus the word then
used as when directing her dragon to
unleash their fiery breath
it seems so but cerned a Targaryen fire
we'll come to King's Landing then he has
lost so much so it sort of be
understandable for her to retaliate well
using dragon fire to kill people is
frowned upon I could see by Danny would
lash out
going back to sin 7 she has lost so much
in deciding to help Jon Snow in the
north
thanks to John's brilliant idea to bring
a white to King's Landing to come in
Cersei to send the troops to the north
Danny wants the dragon Sansa Stark who
has taken over ven FL in Jon's absence
treats Danny like a guarded enemy even
though of NFL would have fallen without
Danny's army center Dragons Den during
the Battle of Winterfell against the
army of the Dead then is that rocky
cavalry was wiped out her army of the
unsullied suffered huge losses as they
sacrifice their lives to protect the
retreating northern soldiers all of
Danny's efforts to free people and
amassing an army to overthrow a rotten
Queen have been threatened while she has
been defending people who are very of
her and still in this episode the Starks
had the nerve to voice their displeasure
with her if helping defend Winterfell
from an undead army is not enough then
it seems nothing will ever change
people's minds about Danny and now with
your having killed her dragon regal and
Cersei having executed me standing in
the wake of Sir Charles death then
circle of trusted friends and loved ones
has shrunk again met Queen be damned at
this point could really anyone blame her
for wanting to lash out
I wouldn't Game of Thrones season 8 is
rapidly coming to an end
much to the dismay of fans and looks
like lovers Jon Snow and Dana Targaryen
could be torn apart in the final two
episodes it has long been theorized that
only one of the pair could survive and
with Dany becoming more and more like
her father the Mad King it's likely it
will be John whose rise I think
throughout the entire episode 5 all
these different people and Dana's loyal
advisers will start telling John how
then is becoming much like her father
wanting to burn the entire King's
Landing and all the innocent people otto
kilcher saying become the queen the
general tell Danny that Varys is
conspiring behind her back and then evil
burn him alive then later I believe
something in the Battle of King's
Landing will trigger Danny totally
foreign blood upon King's Landing and
that's when Tyrion will probably decide
that Varys was right after all and
that's internal all-star telling John
that Danny's death queen and they need
to stop her
at the end that the king's landing has
been burned down and many innocent
people have died
I can see junk you and Danny perhaps
that's why he was resurrected to stop
Danny fencer convinced that's his
destiny and at this point I can see it
happening after - I will probably take
the black again for killing Danny and
we'll go back to the womb and become
1,000 Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
for some fans decision to cast Danny as
an evil queen feels like unearned
turning the story since the first season
Danny has been determined to sit on the
Iron Throne
but never has she been so single-minded
so as to le innate and caused fear in
her closest allies she was after all the
breaker of chains the woman who was
going to break the wheel in order to
keep the parallel plot lines going the
show presented Aeneas an unabashed hero
for seven seasons she and John proved
the most popular heroes to cheer for not
only because they cheated death but
because they spent time with those who
weren't like them and learned to
understand them they saved the exiled
and enslaved
now with just a few episodes led the
writers are determined to tear down it's
going to be so bitter II Danny truly
goes mad and John will have to kill her
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace